vous arrivez au moment opportun parce
que je viens juste de recevoir mes
cadeaux c'est un peu noël avant l'heure
pour moi parce que j'ai reçues les les
cadeaux de gbb du coup les lots des
gagnants
le gbb comprenait le grand beat box
battle l'équivalent du championnat du
monde
l'événement avait lieu à varsovie en
novembre voici une des performances qui
ont valu à martin alias super nova et
son partenaire foot boxe 10 de remporter
la compétition en duo
[Musique]
les enfants ils font des bruits bizarres
avec leur bouche et puis ils arrêtent en
grandissant ben moi j'ai jamais arrêté
quand j'avais peut-être 13 14 ans on
était dans les transports en commun à
bruxelles avec mes potes et on faisait
des bruits bizarres avec nos bouches
pour pour voir la réaction des gens en
fait et jusqu'à ce qu'il ya un mec qui
viennent chez nous et qui disait les
gars vous faites du beatbox et génial le
beatbox une révélation des années durant
il s'entraîne seul jusqu'à une première
compétition en 2013 et un titre de vice
champion de belgique depuis il accumule
les récompenses et veut aussi
transmettre sa passion avec
l'association orléans beatbox il
intervient à saint-jean-de-la-ruelle
lors d'ateliers périscolaire à la maison
pour tous ça donne
c'est un peu comme si on écrivait des
partitions mais à la portée des enfants
qui ont pas fait de solfège en utilisant
des lettres de la langue française qu'on
va traduire en beatbox
on travaille avec cette association
depuis des années on adore travailler
avec eux ils sont les enfants sont très
captif et voilà c'est c'est très
chouette autres
captifs et surtout captiver et désireux
de faire entendre leurs phrases
[Musique]
limitée
et tombe mal non pas j'ai plus peur de
faire des activités m'a pris des sceaux
et on apprend un peu
puisque quelque chose chaque jour sur le
box qu'est ce que tu as appris par
exemple
qui faut pas se moquer des autres
supernova le bruxellois installé à
orléans
tout part d'une rencontre il ya quelques
années avec son confrère jean beat box
moi j'avais le projet de créer une
communauté beatbox sur orléans et voyant
ma détermination il est venu et puis bah
forcément c'est motivé aussi à 2 à des
marchés à trouver des nouveaux
partenaires c'est lui qui m'a dit allez
viens on fait des ateliers et puis bam
le dimanche soir j'étais là quoi et on a
commencé à travailler ensemble et mais
je me disais aussi à côté de ça je
pourrais mettre en place mais projets
musicaux
avec post il est dit deux artistes de la
scène rap harley annese les projets
musicaux doit voir le jour en 2022
[Musique]